there are
tons of talented people around the world
who will never have the Good Fortune to
be able to come to MIT because we're a
small place
but who are perfectly capable of
handling MIT quality MIT hard material
today on Chalk radio making sense of
computer programming for everyone
if we could make that accessible to them
and they use that to change careers or
to start an Enterprise or do something
how can that be anything but good
I'm Sarah Hansen my guest for this
episode wears many hats at MIT he's
taught computer science for almost four
decades and serves as mit's Chancellor
for academic advancement he also serves
as the interim vice president for open
learning at MIT which ocw is a part of
so yes that technically makes him my
boss
this very busy man's name Eric Grimson
you might be familiar with Eric from his
very popular introduction to computer
science courses on ocw there's 6001
introduction to computer science and
programming in Python and 6002
introduction to computational thinking
and data science he also has an intro to
python mooc on mitx which recently
surpassed 2 million enrollments
for this episode we're going to break
down what makes this introductory
computer programming courses so
effective and what he recommends for
newcomers to the field
to start I was curious what computer
science and more specifically his
specialty computer vision looked like
when he first entered the field
I started in computer vision 47 years
ago
and so it's fun to see where it's come
over 47 years in 1975 it didn't do very
much AI was something you scraped off
the bottom of your shoe and today it's
everywhere it literally was Punch Cards
which you only now see in museums the
experience was
you would go to a what's called a
teletype you would type in these things
that would be a set of Punch Cards which
have holes in them that would then get
read in order to read in instructions if
you wanted to run a program you got a
budget because it cost to run on a
computer if you had an infinite Loop in
your code you were in deep trouble
because it would just keep running and
burn up all of your budget and you were
done for the rest of the term to run it
you submitted your deck to an office and
you waited an hour and you came back to
get your print out
you can imagine this was not fun
students used to walk around with these
boxes of Punch Cards in them and the
worst thing that would happen would be
you trip and fall
and your cards now are spread out all
over the floor and you have no idea how
to put them back into order you don't
want to program that way
now we have autonomous vehicles face
recognition even technology assisted
surgery
we built
some of the pioneering systems for
what's often referred to as image guided
surgery
the idea is
subject sadly has a brain tumor it needs
to come out you want the surgeon to get
it out without doing any other damage
subject will go through an MR scan will
build a very detailed three-dimensional
model of that subject so all of the
different tissues here's cerebral spinal
fluid here's uh it's skull here's white
matter gray matter here's motor cortex
here's the tumor then we very accurately
align that with the actual patient on
the operating table
and it lets the surgeon have X-ray
vision they can see inside the patient
they can operate through very narrow
openings but it's as if they see the
entire patient opened up
helping people enhance their skills and
abilities is something Eric cares deeply
about I asked him about bringing people
into the field who might not ever have
considered a career in computer science
one of the things I love about MIT
is that I think there's a deep held
belief that
anybody with enough curiosity
ought to be able to explore a field and
we ought to be able to teach at a level
that opens it up to them
now there's a little bit misleading you
want to do quantum physics you need some
math background but to me when I hear
young people say I'm not good at this or
I really don't think I could do that my
reaction is you haven't given it a
chance my career at MIT I've almost
always taught large introductory courses
my colleagues tell me it's because I'm
not capable of teaching Advanced courses
but my view is that's the place where
you can reach out and grab somebody's
interest
one of the most important things about
teaching an introductory course is
making sure your audience can grasp the
material
this is something Eric gives serious
thought to and it's part of what makes
him such an effective instructor
I think there are two parts
to how I would approach trying to
explain something
the first one is maybe a little silly
but I think it carries with the student
and I'm doing it now
when I'm talking you'll notice when I'm
gathering my thoughts
I pause
I do that because when I was a junior
faculty member a senior colleague
teaching a course I was helping with
he was a card-carrying member of the
actor's guild I don't know what he had
done but he was an actor he talked about
how a verbal tick
um and er can just annoy a listener to
the point where they start
tuning out and so part of presenting is
being conscious of how you're projecting
how you're saying things how you are
interacting because it should be a
conversation what I always try and do
when I'm thinking about presenting a
concept in class
especially a complicated concept
is to try and put myself in the position
of the student
I know this stuff at least I should I've
been teaching it for 40 years but don't
just assume that I know it
what are the places that might be
confusing what are the detailed steps
something may look obvious to me it is
not to a novice in the air my
explanations I hope come across as this
very specific very logical sequence of
steps
one other trick that I've learned over
again a long time of teaching
and this I think surprised to some of my
current students you know I've been
teaching this class for a very long time
I'll do a complete dry run
the night before at least once twice
sometimes three times
I want to know the exact timing I want
to know where I need to hit a certain
Mark in my class but also my experience
is if I in my mind say oh I know how to
explain that and then I get up in front
of 600 students and I get in the middle
of the explanation and I go oh crap you
know I just messed it up
I raise it because for people that want
to be a teacher
practice rehearse go through these
things because it will be natural when
you're in the middle of that explanation
I'd like to talk for a minute about your
use of specific examples in your
lectures particularly I noticed you used
a New England Patriots example this sort
of I guess explain and engage
well I won't do it this year because
they're not going to do nearly as well
as they used to but uh
one of the things I try and do when I'm
thinking about examples
is I'd like to pull in something that
doesn't feel dry and boring
but can relate to something a student
has interest in
it might be something from biology where
it's covid-19 and how do you think about
actually controlling that which is a
lecture that we do in one of our classes
I used the pages just because I happen
to be a fan I've been in New England for
47 years but I also knew that there were
a lot of students in the class whether
it was the Patriots or some other team
it was something they could relate to of
how do you think about
clustering players which is the example
we did we were using grouping to try and
categorize players and so are there
physical characteristics that would tell
you what this player is likely to be
able to do whether you're doing a
football fantasy team or not is
irrelevant but but you want that example
another thing that makes this teaching
so effective is his emphasis on student
participation
for many people of my generation the
phrase that sometimes uses they're the
sage on the stage
they go down into The Well of a big
lecture hall and they give a performance
and some of them are phenomenal there
are great teachers at MIT and other
places that really hold an audience well
but it's a performance
it shouldn't be it should be a dialogue
it should be a conversation that's why I
think skilled teachers of a newer
generation realize it's that dialogue
it's that engagement that's as important
as the performance that you're putting
on you want a partner in exploring a
journey through material
in keeping with Eric's emphasis
audiencing Gantt we asked you to send us
some questions you'd like to ask him we
gathered some of our favorites from
Twitter Instagram and YouTube
what advice do you have for medical
students interested in computer science
and its applications to Medicine
great question
study it it's going to change medicine
absolutely dramatically take some
courses in computer science especially
in machine learning it's already changed
in the field whether it's discovery of
new drugs or it's dealing with better
diagnosis or is dealing with just
personalizing medicine Healthcare is
going to change dramatically over the
next five to ten years and if you're not
comfortable
with the idea of using computation
thinking a little bit like a computer
scientist you're not going to be the
best physician or surgeon or clinician
that you could be absolutely crucial
that you'd be comfortable with those
kinds of ideas
from Instagram
what is the best way to get into an AI
or machine learning career with little
experience in the subject
go online and take a course
that's an obnoxious plug but go online
and take a course I would add two things
to it which is
don't be intimidated there's a lot of
deep math behind cutting-edge AI
algorithms and if you're really
interested go study it getting a sense
of what those tools can do doesn't need
a ton of background knowledge but take a
class on it take a couple of classes on
it the same way that in medicine if you
don't know some computation you're not
going to be successful it's hard to find
a field today where if you're not
comfortable with what AI can do
you're not going to be a successful go
take a course
I think you'll appreciate that hate this
one this was Facebook what is the worst
computer science joke
Grimson has ever heard
the worst computer science joke oh my
goodness
I can tell you my worst choke if you
really want to ask the worst computer
science joke well three
programmers walk into a bar
and put up their hand with two fingers
raised and say
we'd like three beers please
why is that a really bad joke in
computer science you do what's called
zero indexing you start at zero one two
so for a computer scientist two fingers
means three yeah that's bad it's really
bad it's really terrible absolutely
terrible Jokes Aside Eric cares deeply
about sharing the joy of teaching and
learning
enthusiasm is contagious and has
translated into one of ocw's most
popular and influential courses
stem why it's so important to him to
share his work with the world Beyond MIT
I'm going to give you a quote from
Raphael Wright when we launched or when
he launched with help with some of us
mitx 10 years ago
as Raphael said there are
tons of talented people around the world
who will never have the Good Fortune to
be able to come to MIT because we're a
small place but who are perfectly
capable
of handling MIT quality MIT hard
material
if we could make that accessible to them
and they use that to change careers or
to start an Enterprise or do something
how can that be anything but good that's
really why I am a huge fan of ocw I'm a
huge fan of moocs on mitx is I hope I'm
a small part of helping somebody improve
themselves
Sarah if I can give you a little story
about five years ago
I got a letter in the mail physical
letter in the mail it's from a young
woman in Texas
who was writing to say I just want to
let you know
I just finished your mooc
she said my background is I have a
bachelor's degree in Russian literature
and I have been unemployed for two years
not a lot of jobs in Russian literature
my husband got tired of me complaining
and said on a dare why don't you go take
a class so I took your class convinced
that I would do really poorly in it
and discovered I like the stuff I was
pretty good at this stuff
I took four or five more moocs and she
said and I'm writing to let you know
that I just started my new job as a
project manager at Google
the fun part about the letter why was it
a physical letter but it was wonderfully
touching she said I know it doesn't make
a big difference but please in finding
clothes to check for fifty dollars it's
my way of saying thank you well it was a
nice gesture my point of this story
if myself or some other faculty member
can have that impact on somebody to get
them a little bit of a nudge they worked
hard to make it happen
but to provide the basis where they now
improve their personal setting why not
how is it anything but good that
somebody's doing a little better because
we made materials available to people
computer science and programming check
out Eric's course materials on ocw all
of them are shared under a Creative
Commons license which means you can keep
them remix them and share them with
others all for free thank you so much
for listening until next time signing
off from Cambridge Massachusetts I'm
your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
opencourseware
MIT chalk radios producers include
myself Brett patchy and Dave leshansky
show notes for this episode were written
by Peter Chipman Eric crimson's ocw
coresight was built by Sheba nemat
Nasser we're funded by MIT open learning
and supporters like you
and for those of you who are not done
with a bad computer science jokes here
are a few more so why are computers not
good boxers at all
because their barks are always worse
than their bites b-y-t-e-s
how did the professor know how to teach
computer science programming to the
inpatient student
he taught the student about computers
bit by bit
what did the computer do on its much
awaited vacation at the beach it had a
great time surfing the net
thanks everyone I'll be here all week
foreign